estos primeros meses del break sheet han
estado bajo la sombra de la pandemia del
coi 19 cuyo efecto no ha permitido ver
el impacto real en la economía británica
aunque lo cierto es que las predicciones
de una catástrofe no se han visto
todavía lo que sí es cierto es el
impacto y la amenaza en la estabilidad y
la unión del reino unido- primero por la
posibilidad cada vez más tangible de un
segundo referendo de independencia en
escocia y segundo por el protocolo de
irlanda del norte esta región para
mantener la estabilidad política y el
acuerdo de paz de 1998 se encuentra del
mercado dentro del mercado único de la
unión europea lo que hace que enviar un
producto desde cualquier ciudad
británica a esa región es considerado un
tipo de exportación lo que por supuesto
está generando traumatismos entre tanto
la población sigue completamente
dividida
una encuesta reciente asegura que sólo
una de nueve personas cambiaría la
manera como votó en el referéndum del